around every now and then I get a little
bit I then I see the look in your eyes
turn around by thighs every now and then
I fall apart it's night like you to say
sorry I was waiting on a different story
and this time I'm
mistaken forand and your heart was
breaking and I've been wrong I've B down
the bottom
of you know Nickelback has been the butt
of jokes for many years which I think is
actually unfair they're far from The
Worst Band out there but they they have
this reputation as the worst band that's
ever existed my stepbrother and I when
you get really angry with me he used to
say Michael if you don't stop if you
don't cut it out I'm going to buy you
the complete anthology of Nickelback for
Christmas no God please no so This song
is called saving me by Nickelback it's
got 196 million views that's it's a
weird thing to be considered in the
popular culture a terrible band but also
to be one of the most popular bands
around Nickelback Mr Kroger take it
away pron gates w't open up for me on
these hands and knees I'm
gring I reach for
you this is taking me back
[Music]
man
my soul all I need is he says explicitly
Heaven's Gates won't up open up for me
so he's alluding he's referring directly
to religion saying prison Gates won't
open up for me I'm on these hands and
knees I'm crawling the prison of this
Mortal life this terrestrial World which
has fallen and broken and involves each
of us committing sins and incurring
debts that we can't pay I'm reaching for
you with while while I'm terrified of
these four walls the these iron bars
can't hold my soul in so he's saying
right I I might be constrained to death
and Brokenness because of because we're
in a fallen world but my soul yearns for
something else and will not be
constrained by the Brokenness of this
world all I need is you come please I'm
calling I I actually think this is a
religious
song
SC
you I'm falling I'm falling show me
was I just put in a time machine back to
2005 I'll show you what I can say it for
me say it to me and I'll leave this life
behind me saying if it's wor saving
me ev's games won't open up for me with
these broken wings I'm falling off I see
is you teach me wrong from right right
only only God can do that ultimately uh
say it for me I'll leave this life
behind me so you know let the dead bury
the dead and leave everything and follow
me say it if it's worth saving me only
one person can save us Heaven's Gates
won't open up for me won't open up for
me they'll open up for you and you can
bring me through Lord but they won't
open up just for me with these broken
wings I'm falling and all I see you even
this imagery of the falling well
ultimately if you keep falling forever
and ever and ever where do you end up
you end up in the pit of Hell I think of
that famous American sermon sinners in
the hands of an Angry God which has this
this notion that we're like a bug like a
little spider you know we're just sort
of like dangling on on a web and we
could just fall at any moment you know
only only god holds us up and and it
that that opens up with the epigraph
from Deuteronomy your foot their foot
shall slide in due
time the city walls ain't got no love
for me I'm on the ledge of the 18th
story oh I scream for you come please
I'm calling all I need from
you I'm falling I'm falling show me what
it's like be the last one standing and
te me wrong from right and I show you
what I can and stand it for me say it to
me and I'll leave this life behind me
say if it's wor saing
me
[Music]
I'm
kind of a disturbing
video I never expected so disturbing a
video to this song which I'm sure I've
heard
before I scream for
you I'm falling I'm falling I'm fall
show me what it's like to be the last
one standing and teach me roll from
right and I'll show you what I can say
it for me say to me and I'll leave this
life behind me say if it's wor me you
know it's never occurred to me this is a
kind of religious song I don't think I'm
reading too much into Nickelback but all
of the
lyrics would seem to be fairly religious
and the the music video kind of suggests
that too cuz it's all a momento more
you know it's this countdown we only
have so many seconds in our lives and
the clock's going to run out at some
point the problem with 2000's music is
there's no Dynamics to it there not
there's no there's no really Crescendo
or diminuendo or retardo no no no no no
no you don't you don't just throw around
the the r word it's all just like a wall
of distorted sound that's always the
same volume and intensity sorry I can't
be
Perfect all in all though this reading
the lyrics has given me a greater
appreciation for Nickelback and
Nickelback will come back by the way
these things come in Cycles mark my
words Nickelback is going to be cool
again someday if it hasn't started
already no God I'm Michael NS this is
the Michael N show see you next time I'm
done I've had it with all this
Nickelback hating right you think that
makes you cool with the cool kids in
school Fred no it just makes me right
you know who might disagree with that
facts 50 million albums worldwide 11th
bestselling Musical of all time
Billboard's most successful rock group
of the last decade six Grammy
nominations 12 junal Awards those count
six Billboard Music Awards two American
Music Awards One People's Choice Award
Canadian and a partridge in a pear
[Music]
tree